regardez les garçons, ils ont peut-être un autre travail pour
vous jetez un œil à ils suivent donc dégoûtant
super dégoûtant super dégoûtant ce
quartier est en plein essor nous pourrions
peindre cet endroit aujourd'hui le vendre demain
et toujours gagner de l'argent oui nous pourrions
jeepers
vous n'êtes pas juste un  peu nerveux dans cette
maison
hé il n'y a rien à
craindre dans cette maison qu'est-ce que tu fais
ici ne peut pas emménager dans la Maison de la chanson
et ne pas lever quelques sourcils ce
ne sont pas juste chanté qu'est-ce que ça veut dire eh bien
c'est cool cet endroit a déjà un surnom
ce qui se passe en ce moment cette
maison a eu un effet étrange sur ma
femme oui papa
et je pense qu'elle pourrait être possédée par un
démon zoné un peu stressé les
[ __ ] trébuchent c'est tellement fou bien sûr que
nous avons  des images d'un chien fantôme et d'un
horrible meurtre de crucifixion pourraient être le
diable vous savez pourrait être une ex-petite amie
sur PCP eh bien vous l'avez vue faire pipi
oui obtenez beaucoup de ceux-ci doivent être
surpris les gens debout ils pensent
que les puces du diable ont fait  debout comme Sant  un
Noël mais je vous assure que nous
aurons certainement besoin d'indemnités journalières si nous sommes
rapidement en train de souper à temps.
de nouveaux seins pour un petit
tour de victoire tu m'as eu à de nouveaux seins guillerets